the buffalo bills last won the afc east
in 1995.
let's think about that 1995 bill clinton
was in the third year of his first term
coach sean mcdermott was playing safety
at william and mary seinfeld and friends
were on their original run on nbc tom
brady was a freshman at michigan and
josh allen the bill's quarterback
he didn't exist he wasn't born he wasn't
alive in 1995. that's how long ago it
was for the buffalo bills to win the
division so as we work our way up the
pft preseason power rankings from 32 to
one we're at number nine in the top ten
for the first time in a very long time
the buffalo bills they deserve their
placement chris i think you agree with
me on that the question is can they take
this potential that they have and turn
it into a division title for the first
time in 25 years yeah it'll be
interesting to see but i mean the
baltimore i mean the baltimore the
buffalo bills are
you know a team that in an organization
that is on a a rise they really are and
they're a team that i think is building
something very special there
to be reckoned with in the afc in the
afc east yeah it's there for them to to
win it this year they're that's the
first time in forever yeah no brady
there's some other issues on the
patriots roster all of that the buffalo
bills you know they were very close to
being better than the patriots last year
and they improved their team once again
this off season i mean i don't know mike
i look at the buffalo roster and really
just sit here and go
damn
where's tell me the weak spot i don't
know there's really not one to be had
other than maybe corner and lack of
depth there we saw josh norman you know
uh pulled his hamstring or has a soft
tissue thing they lost star to star
lotulele right i believe because he
opted out because of kovitz yes so that
was big but they have lots of defensive
linemen i mean i just look at the roster
and think man brandon bean sean
mcdermott they've really orchestrated
something really special and strong
there and they've created a culture and
everything that you like to where i
think buffalo is going to be very legit
this year and legit for the next few
years
yeah and look the the opportunity is
there at least until they signed cam
newton in new england but still there's
that transition that sense that maybe
this is a chance for someone to break
the new england stranglehold on the
division they've won it every year since
2008 really every year since 2003 with
the exception of 2008 when tom brady
tore an acl week one and the dolphins
managed to steal the division title the
patriots were eleven and five that year
and still somehow didn't make the
playoffs they would this year under the
seven team expansion that they now have
in both conferences but
what what i mean
what do the bills you know nuts and
bolts need to do yeah to overcome
the patriots where do you see
the the the push coming from is it a
defensive thing is it an offensive thing
is it josh allen
finally fulfilling what you've seen in
him since before he was drafted what is
it specifically going to take to make it
happen to me it's it is the offense
going maybe to that you know next level
as far as you know they've played a game
the last two years where
yeah they've managed josh allen a little
bit they play through their defense they
take a few aggressive shots down the
field here and there maybe run him but
want to run the ball and play that way
and you know we saw he did a lot of
highlight reel exciting things his
rookie year last year played the
position more clean you know definitely
wasn't as reckless with the football
certainly showed some improvement with
accuracy but now where i'm excited and
to me this is where the next step is
mike you know year two and the brian day
ball system that new england scheme
we've talked about it already on the
show it's not easy it's complicated
between that and everybody there being
used to it the offensive line with some
young studs on there and now stefan
diggs into the mix with cole beasley and
john brown and dawson knox who's a
really damn like good tight end that
looks like he's got a bright future in
the nfl you start to go wait
this might be a team this year where
they they don't have to play through
their defense and manage josh allen and
run the ball they might be able to go on
a certain week go you know what
we're clearly better than this team on
the offensive side of the ball let's put
the pedal in the metal let's not play a
game to where you know where it's 20 to
17 and we got to sweat it out at the end
they might this year just go damn we
trust josh allen we got weapons we're
going to try to blow your butt out and
we're going to try to win by 30. and i
think that's what's exciting to me is
that they might have that aspect of them
this year where they're not having to
play you know that game of managing him
and the defense and all that
we've seen the ravens throw caution to
the wind with lamar jackson and let him
run have have not just scrambles that
are authorized but designed run plays
for him yeah we've seen the bills be
more careful with josh allen remember
last year we saw it coming in the
playoffs when it's single elimination
they're not going to keep the bubble
wrap they're going to tell them to go
out there and run the ball should they
do that all the time
should they just use this guy to his
full ability every week and if he gets
injured that's why you have a backup but
you're not going to be as good as you
can be if you don't embrace the full
capabilities of your quarterback in josh
allen well i mean yes and no i mean i i
want them to embrace it and have the
threat of that but i don't want him
running the ball too consistently on a
week-to-week basis i mean we saw even in
that game in the wild card game against
the houston texans as that game went on
and they ran him more and more the
defense got used to it
and this is where you go wait you know
the team's got to save the player a
little bit because he's too tough and
stubborn and you know he wanted to lower
his head he was taking on linebackers at
the end of that game against the houston
texans refusing to go down
plus you know they have something
special there you know as far as
potential at receiver and this offense
and everything like that to where you
know allen has a chance to be a
superstar he has a chance to be the guy
there for the next 10 12 years and i
just wouldn't risk that with him not
saying he's patrick mahomes but i think
he could be one of those guys that opens
our eyes up a lot over the next 10 years
about what he's doing on the field so
for the bigger picture of things that's
why i would say no save them those big
moments when you called it last year in
the wild card game then you might unveil
you know a few tricks that you got up
your sleeve as far as him running the
ball and game plan design runs back up
quarterbacks on the roster currently
matt barkley jake fromm and davis webb
surely at least one of them will be gone
before the season begins likely webb
uh if josh a quick fill in the blank if
josh allen misses any significant time
due to injury their season is what oh i
mean in the balance it's not over
because the defense is too damn good and
then i think between singletary and then
their second or third round pick moss
zach moss from utah who i love
i just think they'll they'll even if
allen went down they're not going to be
as fun to watch on offense and explosive
but i think between their o-line and
being able to run the football they'll
play a style of football we just saw
them play last year and the year before
where yeah a few shots here and there
but we're going to play through our
defense and run the ball to where they
won't be as good but i still think they
can be a pain in the butt and uh be very
competitive that way even with a matt
barkley if he had to come in
if they and look i i'm hesitant to even
mention this because i'll be accused of
creating a jinx by even saying don't do
it to my boy
i'm not going to do it okay good look at
this he didn't do it i cannot believe it
whoo
yes don't jinx my boy i'm just i'm just
trying to wonder aloud at what point
they would look outside for an upgrade
over matt freaking barclays that's well
that's my question i i hear you yeah
you're right he's an unproven commodity
now the one thing they'll be able to
look at is guy played a lot of college
football as we know and even last year
when he came in uh and i can't remember
exactly what that game was i want to say
it's new england when josh that's not a
good sign well no but he did some good
things he did he was showed he was
capable of moving the offense and making
a few throws and things like that too so
i would bet he has given them enough
confidence to be that guy but yeah
you're right it's certainly risky i mean
josh allen is a super superstar type
talent i mean we saw what he can do
running the ball we know he has an
unreal arm i mean come on we're talking
about him and mahomes having a throw off
if that doesn't tell you what kind of
arm the guy has and i don't know what
else does i mean nobody wants to like no
one raises their hands and says i'll
challenge patrick my homes to a throw-up
nobody does that unless you know you
have like a holister for a right arm and
he does so uh he has a chance to be a
superstar and i think they're building
something really awesome there in
buffalo
yeah i definitely think they need him
for uh you know at least 12 of the games
if they're gonna have any chance at
getting to the postseason or more
importantly at winning the division for
the first time since
1995.
last year you said that that the offense
needs that star player that go-to guy
yeah and it's been hard to really peg
where stefan diggs fits because he's had
the production but he's kind of been
lost in the shuffle in minnesota dalvin
cook last year adam thielen has kind of
you know stepped up and actually has a
better contract than stefan diggs at
least he did before diggs got his
contract tweaked by the bills is diggs
the star that they need to make that
offense everything it can be i think he
is yes i do diggs is such a well-rounded
wide receiver you know that's where to
me his greatness is like you know i know
we've talked about it a little but he's
the kind of guy like we saw in the
divisional playoff game who can burn
somebody down the sidelines in a
straight go route and say sia and yet he
can run those like julian edelman cole
beasley over the middle option route
jerk routes where you got to be on the
same page as the quarterback and all
that he can do all of that too so that's
where it's really cool and to me that's
what's cool between yeah beasley can be
that slot guy work the middle of the
field and then diggs and john brown can
dabble and dabble in it let alone be
mismatched one-on-one nightmares outside
because of their pure speed that way and
then when you have a quarterback that's
got a big arm and then you know an
offensive line and an offensive
coordinator and a head coach that are
willing to run the ball and be a little
patient with that man i think it can
just set itself up for some really big
time exciting plays there in buffalo
this year
you know a year ago leshaw mccoy was the
starting running back in buffalo they
dumped him in the final cut down devin
singletary is the guy that they are
hoping will will really develop but with
zack moss it is an indication that that
maybe they're going to share the load or
yeah that maybe they have some
reservation or or they just don't want
to get themselves into a spot where they
have one guy that generates the kind of
numbers where you have to pay them a
king's ransom to keep them around but
you know the rest of the offense again
once they start producing
then they the names become stars and uh
whether or not they produce is going to
hinge largely on the offensive line how
do you feel about the blockers who are
available to josh allen and company well
they got one of the best centers in
football and mitch moore's so he's
phenomenal right i like him as far as
their tackles are concerned the guard
you know they drafted a cody ford a few
years ago out of oklahoma he's a road
grader all right so i like him you know
they just signed deion dawkins so they
drafted out of pittsburgh a few years
ago they signed him to a long-term deal
because they like him at left tackle you
know quentin spain the guard you know
mcdermott's he's built this is what he
does he built a big physical team and
you know just as we start to look at you
know these teams in the top 10 and some
of the teams we've gone through before
and we wonder what's successful about
them you just go well
damn you know they have a front seven on
defense and an offensive line on the
that side of the ball where they don't
lose battles you know they don't even
when they play the best defenses or
offenses in football the worst thing
that happens to them is a stalemate and
there's there's a lot of you know
positives about stalemates so i look at
that offensive line and think it has a
chance to be
you know i think it's cusp of top ten
and i think it could be one of those old
lines by like the end of the year we
would go ooh is this one of the five
best offensive lines in football i think
it has that type of potential yeah most
recently they picked up brian winters
after he was abruptly cut by the jets to
save some cash in cap space all right
defensively
16.2 points per game allowed last year
by the buffalo bills will they be better
worse or the same this year
um
i think they're gonna be better i do i
mean i this was the number three defense
in football last year i don't know about
the points per game thing that'll be you
know that's tough but i think they're
gonna be every bit in that range mic of
top two three four defenses and all the
football you know you got a shutdown
corner you got an awesome safety duo
you've got an unbelievable linebacking
duo in edmonds and milano then you got
pass rushers you know with hugh and ed
oliver hughes and ed oliver and that
bunch there to where you know you just
look at them across the board and you
just go man there's nothing not to like
they got size guys off the edge and
mario addison i mean uh that's i think
the defense is gonna be special i think
it'll be one of the most dominant in
football
and in three years with sean mcdermott
as the head coach you can see on that
graphic what they have done and where
they have ranked and they keep getting
better chris i think that's the key
how would you attack the bill's defense
where's the vulnerability if you were
designing an offense
it's not easy because mcdermott is one
of those guys mike too where you know is
game plan specific it's not like oh this
is what we do and we're not going to
change up and we're not going to mess up
and we'll just play fast no mcdermott is
to me this is why he's one of the great
minds of the sport some plays i just i
go i don't know what coverage this is
but i know all his guys have dropped
into a zone exactly where the receivers
are trying to get open there's seven
guys over here and there's only three
receivers and to me that's where he's a
really special you know breakdown
tendency type of head coach to where i
can't give you an answer where you break
it down i don't know it's not easy to me
you'd have to the one other corner is
the question mark right now opposite of
true davious white levi wallace josh
norman when they have to play man-to-man
or they don't have help of a safety i'm
attacking them until you you know show
me that they can
stop people
fun fact also that i hadn't previously
realized sean mcdermott sounds a lot
like phil sims
and everyone else
chris ever tries to impersonate
uh best case worst case buffalo bills i
mean best case
afc's champs
they're that i think the super bowl they
could be in the super bowl i wouldn't be
i'll say it they could win the super
bowl i think their team is there set up
and i'm not betting money on it okay but
i'm telling you the best case with this
team the way it's set up yes i'm
throwing out super bowl there for the
buffalo bills worst case
like it would have to take some sort of
injury to a josh allen or something like
that to where then i go oh they you know
they just missed out in the playoffs
they're seven and nine or something like
that i don't see them being you know
falling too far off
there will be a spike in downloads of
the peacock app in western new york
today now that
chris has pegged the bills not just to
get to the super bowl which bill's fans
remember all too well four years in a
row but to actually
win the super bowl that would be amazing
you know how many times have we seen a
team
that
has just kind of been hanging around on
the edge of contention then all of a
sudden they find the gas pedal they
become great and we're like yeah you
know what we probably should have saw
that right and and if josh allen is
going to fulfill his potential if he's
going to cement himself as the second
best quarterback from the class of 2018
behind lamar jackson who knows maybe he
could be every bit as good
as lamar jackson now that he's getting
experience and that he has the weapons
that he needs to move the ball down
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports